apologies
of interest for reporting today
okay we come to item three which is the
report item 3.1 the victor the minister
[Applause]
report
uh thank you you worship
uh this is a very important matter which
is probably going to only occur in once
a generation if we're lucky
councillors have spent quite a lot of
time
considering
the matter and considering the
information that the
government has provided
we've also commissioned independent
advisors to
consider the proposal to create four
entities to essentially
deliver the three waters in new zealand
the proposal is to have councils as
owners of those four entities
but the normal
relationship an owner has to the
delivery of service is not evident
through the process the government is
recommending
which is to have quite a significant
separation between
waimakuri district council in this case
and the new entity and what it would do
i think members from previous briefings
are aware of the proposal for governance
which
essentially would have six
appointed um people representing local
government interests for most of the
south island
six from naitamu that group in term
would appoint a committee that in turn
would appoint the directors so that is
the governance arrangement that's
proposed
which is quite different to the
current arrangements that are in place
from the survey that was undertaken by
the council to assist you to understand
what your constituents are feeling on
the subject
of those who participated 95 percent
felt that the status quo should remain
in terms of the ownership side effects
of local influence over
the sort of order decisions that need to
be made on the day
this council has
over the years invested significantly in
the
three waters assets
and has been recognised as having good
asset asset activity management systems
made appropriate provision for
um future expenditure in the three boys
areas going forward
um the information that was provided by
this council to the government
survivors wix which was then
subsequently modeled
uh in the view of your professional
advisors did not fully reflect the
reality of the financial position going
forward
and
notwithstanding that some of that
information was corrected essentially
the national modeling approach
was still continued with
so for the reason set out in the paper
uh it's recommended that the council
doesn't support the current proposal
there's a range of reasons for that
including the loss and lack of influence
over local
issues that would be
um would come to pass with the
university
um
we also believe there's a professional
because you've got a form of local
government you've got a new framework
coming which will be regionally based
for spatial planning
and that spatial planning will identify
where critical corridors need to be
invested in which improves through
watershed transport
and housing obviously
and it would be appropriate to try and
align these reforms and have a package
which sets out the first local
government where
the waters fit in and how that then
aligns to planning
as a growth council
the integration of
planning decision making and where
growth should be and provision services
and retirement and their development
contribution funding is actually very
important
uh with an entity which is looking after
most of the south island to have that
local eye mercury voice
going forward will be challenging
mechanisms can be put in place to try
and achieve that voice but it wouldn't
be as simple and easy as it is today
for this district to align the
investment with the
needs of the community for
additional housing and the various
infrastructure there's also question
marks as to how reward schemes would
be fair under this new system and there
are a number of questions around the
stormwater side
as to how that would work in practice as
well
at the simplest level the government's
proposal is that
stormwater assets linked to growing
um
would be retained by the council but all
other student assets would be part of
the community
but it's never quite as simple as that
when you look at the nature of
waterflows and
funding and all those sorts of things
there was also
question marks over the
potential costs that future residents
would pay for
the government's modeling suggests
significantly increased costs over our
current modelling
what we do know is that when you're
trying to plan
for 30 years that's a very difficult
thing to do with any degree of precision
and accuracy
so for all of those reasons you worship
my report
which has the support of the executive
team
for the reason set out in the
recommendations we believe that the
council
should close the
government's proposal at this stage that
there should be the cause to try and
integrate the other reforms
and other alternatives should be
investigated which were
uh looked at a recursive fashion early
on in the process
but once the decision was made
to head down this four entity model
consideration of different ways to
achieve reform was essentially not
debated
at a level that i would have expected
that to occur
so i think foreign
just in the recommendations that we've
received
um
just wondering could you elaborate on
what that statement actually refers to
because it does seem a very general
statement and
we don't want to pull it to the track of
the general advertising like we've been
shown in tree waters so far
[Applause]
um
it's it's a good good question um
the world meetings include economic
social cultural environment
with the current planning arrangement
and the ability of the council to align
three waters investment with
its planning framework with the ltp
investment
and so on that you're trying to
put water assets in place
to reinforce the growth of townships
also putting them in place to support
choice and housing
styles and lifestyle living that goes
with them
so
if you have those sort of decisions
being made by an entity which is
then you may not be able to get the best
outcomes for your community for
let's say a business that needs a lot of
water or that may not suit the
investment companies timetable at the
time that you wish to was at the moment
there's part of conversation between
yourselves
um developer
and your water department whereas in the
future that would be more difficult to
achieve so it's it's that kind of
thinking that underpins that statement
is it possible that statement could be
just
a little bit more specific
because well-being
tends to talk about social well-being
and i just wonder whether we need to
clarify how that relates to
our submission
just asking for your suggestion
um
well i think it's a question for the
team i think the submission probably
does pick that up
recognizing this is the council report
and both it's recommended that the
council report and the submission will
go to the minister as well as
preventative years and so on
because if we come for too many of the
reasons here we end up with a very whole
recommendation statement which to be
honest some of the early versions were
much longer than this people produced
them
sorry supplementary i just
is there a way to
still categorize how that impacts
because
it could be measured
and
the well-being of the community is
affected by poor water so
the well-being in here we're talking
about
our inability to
grow and zone appropriately for our
community or
is that really what you're trying to
refer to
it certainly is part of it it's the
alignment of growth economic development
and so on and using water and
infrastructure provision and it's timing
with other sus
the best
this particular regard to the
integration of
the provision of three waters
infrastructure with growth needs
and economic development opportunities
today
rather than one going to government with
the whole series of amendments
it would look better
[Applause]
particular regard to the provision of
three waters
three words of infrastructure and growth
as an enabler of
economic development
growth and
sorry
growth
[Applause]
infrastructure and growth as an enabler
of economic development
everyone's here on that yeah
okay better questions
would it be possible also to make sure
that we send all this to the prime
minister it will be thank you i'll cover
that shortly
okay um all right so we've come to the
recommendation um
3.1 i'm going to move it
see if this
comes just want to say uh
firstly in all my years of public office
many of you have been in the same
situation too
i've never been approached or stopped
as much as i have been around the topic
of three waters
many many phone calls and
even with controversial topics such as
the stadium i've never been
approached as much as i have about this
matter
i support the recommendations
i want to say how proud i am of our
staff
for the work that they've done jared
libby colin kelly and team
uh alastair and our comms team chief
melbourne is our finance manager and jim
as our chief executive
we have all worked hard and provided
expert
superb advice and guidance
on this in gym in particular i
appreciate
all the advice and guidance that you've
given me
we've had a number of phone calls and
zoom calls and
meetings
across
canterbury across new zealand
today's report and submission is
evidence of all that hard work
i'm proud of you all as counsellors uh
as colleagues it hasn't been an easy
matter
but as a team we've supported each other
and i really appreciate how we've worked
together on this particular matter
and it hasn't really been easy at times
to leave this matter
i felt at times that
we've been out on our own as a council
or part of a very small minority on this
particular issue
we can be very proud that our work
in other councils is starting to turn
the sentiment around of a number of
councils in this country
and i see christchurch was unanimous
in its opposition uh yesterday
president of local government new
zealand said on a poll recently
that in his opinion he felt less than 10
councils would opt in
we're going to see over this next period
of time
whether that's correct what i'm picking
up is
it's a very small minority that are
going to support this but we'll see
whether that rings true in the coming
period of time
i think we were absolutely right
to go out and ask our community
after all they paid for the three waters
s6
it's only by being informed that it was
important that we are informed by our
community before we reach
such an important decision as jim said
it's one of probably one of the most
important decisions
as a council we will make over this term
if not within this whole since this
council was established back in 99.
as we know the community came back to us
after 3844
the highest number of surveys that we've
um even received your response to a
consultation item
the next nearest item would have been at
the time of the
2018 long-term plan
and the 800 submissions we received
which were largely to do with the
stadium at the time so just to provide
context
uh as we all know that's a very high
return rate
i acknowledge all the governance staff
and all others that have helped
input all that material for us so we've
got uh that
in front of us to consider
and as we know
through that 95 of those who responded
advised us to opt out
the overwhelming reason that our reasons
uh
were that residents weren't happy about
losing local control
and the locals say over their essence
and infrastructure that was the
overriding reason
they're also concerned that we may end
up
subsidising other communities throughout
this country
today as a council we will give our
support to the voice of our community
to inform our position over this time we
haven't just stepped back
we sent 28 questions to the minister and
on a call i was on yesterday with the
minister and d.i.a
there was 14 000 questions that have
come from councils
throughout the country
we've convened special meetings with
department internal affairs
we've engaged independent consultant
advice award
our expert and professional staff have
analysed all the material
other experts castalia
morrison line and even the former chief
executive of christchurch city council
mike richardson
have
put together material
they've all reached the same conclusion
that the four-entity
one-size-fits-all model
is not right for our community and
ultimately for our country
the scottish wix model
might be okay
for scotland but it's not okay for here
30 other models as jim mentioned were
not adequately considered
instead the government landed
on this one model
i'm very proud we can all be very proud
of what we've achieved here
over the last 20 years
and in fact longer than that
but over that period of time we've
invested over 100 million dollars
these haven't been uh
easy conversations to help with our
community over upgrading water supplies
i remember the summer hill the oxford
the cast
uh the wistiation
points
you and i remember that very well
there weren't easy conversations to have
but absolutely necessary to make sure
that we were upgrading our water to make
sure that our communities have safe
and reliant on drinking water sources
and yes there was a council on the ocean
outfield some years ago too
one of the largest projects this
council's ever embarked on 36 million
a huge piece of work
and
show real vision of all sides of the
council with making an investment
we've got a 30-year infrastructure
strategy we know
we know the condition of our assets and
we know where the investments required
and it sits within our long-term team
and sits there knowing what we've got to
find over this period of time
i want to remind the department of
attendant peers and the minister as i
did yesterday
of the good faith in which we entered
this process
and that we trust that similar good
faith will be shown
regarding the council's ability and
their own decisions
to opt out if they choose to do so
extremely disappointed with the
government's advertising campaign
grossly misleads with sponge coming out
of text and
waterways it's not an accurate
reflection of where we are at
this
discussion up in the first place and
quite correctly and offensive through
our sector we have to endure such
advertising
the minister finally acknowledged that
yesterday that the advertising wasn't
ideal
but she said it has raised awareness um
and
there where it wasn't foreign
hardly an act of good faith in my
personal family
with this in mind i have very real
concerns about the department of
chemical peers leading the exercise of
the future for local government i hope
they don't go down a similar part of the
advertising model that they've done to
date
personally i think this should be led by
our sector and not by department of
detail affairs
on three waters uh i think uh lgnz and
our lobbyist are not adequately
representing our secret
and following today's meeting i'm going
to write to the president asking that he
calls a special
see members views on three daughters
members that's our council's views
at the present time
they've signed as we know a historic
agreement without
our say
and this is being used by the minister
quite often in conversations there's
points where
uh you know
your sector is working alongside us we
have a heads of agreement never saw our
opinion on that before it was signed and
i'm pretty confident other councils will
get this call
as is in the motion
we urge the government to press the
pause button in fact
go fast rewind back to the start
and start this process again
and work with councils to look
alternatives
embed the new water regulated first
we've got far-reaching powers before the
regulator and can require councils that
aren't performing to make that
investment
and then build them later it's huge
house
and look at other alternatives like the
old drinking water subsidy scheme
or the ncta co-funding partnership model
there are lots of alternatives
and i'm sure all councils that i speak
to and i'm sure you've been in touch
with would welcome that opportunity to
look at alternatives
in our leisure that we're going to see
following this meeting today
we are inviting the minister to meet
with us
i really hope she takes up this
opportunity
as i know i'm sure we would all welcome
that conversation
the model we have and how we operate at
present time is not broken i'm not going
to say that there are other councils in
the country
that do need to look at
further investment but a one size fits
all as is proposed here is not the right
answer we need to go back
and have a real look at
what is proposed
then look at the other alternatives
before landing on one
uh to support the recommendations that
have been
well canvassed by us all and i hope we
can show that we're in a unanimous
position today thank you
the other speakers
council readings
thank you mr mayor for those comments
i'd like to echo some of them and also
to thank you for incorporating
colleagues suggestions of the regulation
water is pretty critical none of us can
survive without it
um it's said to be the new gold of the
21st century so it is something of high
value it's a very serious topic and i
suspect that's the reason why the
community
was a pretty boring topic of
infrastructure and water have gotten
behind it and i'm just astounded
everywhere i go and people seem to know
about it
and my experience is similar to yours
that people are very well informed and
certainly not in favor of opting in
um
i think there are two main issues here
with this proposed model the first is
financial
and i'll say shortly that i think it's a
flawed financial model
secondly the question of governance
and the game that's somewhat loaded and
undemocratic
i'm sure all of us will accept the need
for good water and environmental
outcomes that is this proposable way to
achieve that
[Applause]
financial well
they really got off to a bad start with
physical financial
data given to us that even i as a
former lawyer and not accountant could
see didn't really add up so they got off
on the wrong foot and as people say if
it's too good to be true
it is so the outcomes were not likable
the memorandum of understanding we
signed last year
uh
we've got eight million for signing up
was really a crude attempt to get us on
board with the proposals
and i probably don't need to remind you
that i voted against the time
turned out to be somewhat of a trojan
horse
it's evolved over time and i think it's
being used the data that we provided
it's being used against us
[Applause]
the outcomes for ratepayers
are implausible and their own staff and
the external consultants have confirmed
that
and the customer report
which woman district council
obtained applies to us i think in the
same way it applied to them
for rain players i see higher costs as
we cross subsidize others who have not
looked after their assets
we have a very good record of investing
wisely and having a long-term
plan
[Music]
we manage paris
appropriately and prudent
not all have done so
the scottish model
overestimated savings and suggested
unrealistic benefits of scale
how on earth you can predict
financial data 30 years of advance is
beyond me
but obviously someone has a crystal ball
entity d
which we
would if this proceeds for part of is
based on the tribal khaki one
it's unrelated to physical catchments
territorial authority boundaries
and in my view how can that possibly
achieve efficiencies that are
given as a reason for the reform
something in the order of 45 percent
over 30 years
these are diverse areas what do we have
in common with the capital and their
water supply
nothing i would suggest
the boundaries are illogical
um the master plan seems to be to use
our good acids to subsidize the
deficiencies of others
the assets will be borrowed on billions
of dollars
and uh spent throughout
entertaining
i particularly took offense at the
sudden definition of ownership which was
referred to as bespoke
it needs no legal definition i've even
come across of ownership and seem to be
a way of trying to sell the concept to
the community that you still own it when
you don't
it's a clayton's form of ownership
our assets are over 600 million dollars
and we're going to get 22 million
dollars for them it's one third of our
business one third of our staff
how can that be a good deal for our
great parents
the second matter of governance
there is a loss of democratic control
that's a bloated there's three layers
to get to the corporate board who will
actually administer the entity
we will have minimal defending input
the memorandum of understanding said
that both parties were then in good
faith
and quote the council will have the
right to choose whether or not they wish
to continue to participate in the reform
programme
beyond the term of the mou
that position appears to be changing
from comments we received from the
minister
last year i signaled by entering the mou
for eight million it might be difficult
to exit the reform programs and i said
tongue-in-cheek
some of you might remember this how
often does the mouse get the cheese back
not very often i suggest
there was supposed to be a voluntary
position
and i say let's hold the government
through that mandate and shouldn't even
be considered given the background of
this proposal
and
if the
there are other risks of the program the
risk of privatization of future and so
on
one of the good things we've done is
engage with our community
and uh the survey that we received
gave us an overwhelming mandate
of what the community thinks
the last thing and i'm probably walking
on too long the role of local government
new zealand is a concern the recent
heads of agreement signed by local
government new zealand states
lgbt commits to supporting endorsing and
promoting three quarters
program and not oppose mandating
but publicly can express its
disappointment
in the quote
i think that's the strength for them
lgbt is supposed to represent us at a
national level
not promote the government's policies to
its members
and finally in conclusion jacinda even
the prime minister three weeks ago said
providers know their communities best
she was referring to the vaccination
program but she's right
and i believe the same applies to three
authors
i would invite the government to listen
and consider the alternatives it needs
to provide solutions to where problems
actually exist
and i would echo your comment mr mayor
that one size does not fit all
finally we need to keep local government
local and i think that's the main point
we need to emphasize so i fully support
and i vote twice for these
recommendations
to vote for me but i'm very much in
favor of the written conductions thank
you thank you councillor
um before i come to council duty just
um for the benefit of council rewards if
you look at um
how
else is uh in the other requests myself
on your behalf
to send our submission resolution
and our report to all members of
parliament
so that includes the prime minister
and it's ready to go once we've made
that decision today it's nice to know i
think
council do so i have council do the
uh council award
and then deserve to pass directions
thank you mars is going to be very
brutal i'm very pleased to see that
[Applause]
[Music]
and i asked the question or i sent a
question
how does the differential between
residential and rural
water work
bearing in mind that only very small
margins for house water drinking and
reply came back no problem irrigation
feeds the stock water
they have absolutely no idea how the
rural sector work
and and does our government really know
how the rural sector work i just found
it absolutely frankly insulting to the
quality of work that our staff have done
for all the work that they've put into
our areas
including the rural sector
and i'm just just really um
and it's quality for all and i really
just can't understand where this
government is at because quite frankly
um
it is insulting to the whole
i have a major issue
with the control of our ratepayers
assets going into an entity which is
undemocratic
and shows this labor government
is following their promises made during
your extensive to-date consultation with
lewi
now this government is trying to deliver
on these promises made
there is no certainty that our council
would have any representation of the six
people on the board and thereby lose
total control of our district's future
our council has acted responsibly it's
not working
thank you our council has acted
responsibly and have sound financial
updates models for the next 30 to 50
years to adequately give great service
and meet the water standards and
infrastructure required
i strongly advocate that we stay firm on
the status quo
but support a government assistance to
needy and unfunded councils to bring
their infrastructure up to date
and i really want to iterate that we
stand firm
and because
i really am concerned that there is a
motive there by this government
and their one motive is joint governance
and that
is not democrat
yes when i first heard about three
waters reform i have looked great and at
this
reformers going to deliver
more swampable rivers of lakes if this
reform is going to deliver safe
clear unchlorinated drinking water great
that would be brilliant and in fact when
i asked my teenage daughters about the
advertising
they they were like it's going to clean
up all their rivers and and that was the
feeling they got from the advertising
campaign
of course it's not
um and i think what really concerned me
is that they never put out a clear
consultation i just cannot believe it
for an issue this important a clear
consultation for the whole of new
zealand explaining what it actually
meant
all the way through the government
confused three waters infrastructure
with fresh water and rivers and
environmental protection
and of course we all want our
environment to be better
but it's not going to be achieved
through these reforms
our council believes in continuous
improvement and we've done a lot of it
particularly since the earthquakes i
don't know how many times the cameras
have gone down the drains to try and
make sure that the structure is working
we have a really good idea of what our
infrastructure is
[Applause]
the thing that we've received but it's
really democracy in action we're hearing
from our people the new zealand people
are speaking up and saying well actually
we're not quite sure this is going to
work in many ways we see this being a
bad thing for our district and a has
been from any part of new zealand
the recent disaster events and floods
and
issues we've had in our district
actually emphasize that we have really
fast local response it gets out of fix
flooding drainage issues fixing jewelry
problems well we had that under an
entity that services the whole south
island
i think not
i can't see efficiencies by just adding
an extra layer of bureaucracy
and so
the
figures just don't add up
it just won't work
[Applause]
what i would really like this government
to do
is please
focus on the councils who need some help
with drinking water i'm not into the
blame game i know that some councils
have realistic actual reasons why they
couldn't afford to bring their
infrastructure up to modern standards
help them
give them some opportunity so that the
ratepayers don't have to
fund the possible bills
but we're not their council
fix the broken sewer systems around the
country to make sure that syrup is not
going into the waterways
but we are not that counsel
let the new water standard regulator
have time
to settle in and do a proper review
and focus on the highest risk
when you do a budget you cannot fix
everything but you start with what means
fixing first
so my message to the government is
please listen
to the people
listen to the voices out there that have
told you we don't understand the
benefits
we can't see
anything that's going to help
we cannot see the efficiencies that
we're looking in the figures that we've
received
and just take a pause take some time
to discuss these issues
with the community with elected
officials and with the experts
our staff who see what actually happens
so
[Applause]
thank you i certainly um agree with
much of the sentiment that um
has put forward particularly in the
confusion that's out there i mean i
i accept um as i think as general here
that there is
certainly
a need for change in the way that our
water services are delivered
and i
welcome the um
the conversation and action to deliver
that and i certainly
listened very hard to the minister about
what was going to be the outcome of
medical forms
and i got a distinct impression that we
were going to get delivered the
freshwater
nps
and i heard it again
she said the same thing
but in fact that's not the case
at all
and
trading on this confusion
out there that
this is an exercise for
the
transfer of um
part of the infrastructure
that
some councils have and some councils
don't have a serious condition
but um and i can't reconcile
the fact that
uh the figures that were asked of this
council and all the councils around new
zealand
and the dashboard that ends up where
our financial people and consultants
that we've
asked to assist here
can't easily marry in fact can't marry
the figures that the government has
put before us through this model and you
know it's as
i've said it wouldn't appear to be
one size fits all i don't have any
particular
difficulty with
a
joint governance model with our treaty
partners because that effect is what has
been put forward that's okay
but
um i think the confusion out
generally
that this is going to deliver what it is
not going to deliver is the thing that
has
stopped me from supporting it i would
like to see other alternatives i would
really like to see
the delivery of the fresh water outcomes
that are um
i thought and
i still have um
an understanding that that's what the
minister is talking about but
it isn't the case here and the confusion
is right
we do have issues to deal with here
we supply we have
relatively young infrastructure and
potable water delivery but in fact we
only supply 76 of
the them the district here 24
are on private wells
just where they will be um
and they
be reformed the um
council who knows and as others have
said
one of the most valuable groups i sit on
is
our local
rural drainage group because in fact
they are people who understand what is
happening
in their patch
and i think we're all
all better um for those groups and staff
as well
i mean to where they they
that type of group fit into this um this
model i've got no idea
and i'm not a fan of ccos and whether
this
is a cco with a
a new sort of frock on
that's fine but um i think the
lack of local
input
again makes me very
nervous of
this whole proposal as i said i i
am open for
change i am open for within this council
having a far better and comprehensive
rating system across the different
districts for water supply
service treatment and land drainage and
still water management
and
i'm forced to conclude that this is not
going to do it
so i would welcome um a further
conversation
more
on more options
but i'm forced here to say that this is
not
this option here is not going to deliver
it for me
but
i wholeheartedly support basically what
been said by everybody particularly
but
one of the other things that we've got
some of the best local staff
in the whole of new zealand we've got
one of our best
water systems in the whole of new
zealand
we comply with our consensus
as a councillor it's actually
really good that i can walk up the main
street of rangira or calhoun
and people don't come and criticize us
because we haven't got a good water
supply
in fact it's the opposite they come
there and they look like the fresh
drinking water
in new zealand and i'm proud of that and
um
so i think we've got to think off the
staff as well i know they get could get
transferred or whatever into new group
on this proposal
but i don't want that i want to keep
what we've got because it's really
really good
we just had a bit of a flood around the
area
our staff cross over and help other
departments in our council
without them
we could be on a back foot and i think
it's very very important
with that side of things
the government has not been upfront
and delivered
proper clarity on the system in fact
they've been misleading on what they've
been stating in their figures and what
have you
i've asked questions of the um
the government on different matters on
figures and all that drama they couldn't
answer them properly and truthfully
that's that's that's not good
they're advertising they've put
three and a half million dollars into
misleading advertising um
that's not good but i don't think
there's any green water in new zealand
to get sludge coming out of the text and
that's the way they're trained all down
from new zealand
the feedback i get from all the people
is they want local control
and that's a very important thing
our staff for local people
they know there's a problem where the
problem is how to fix it we've got our
local contractors that
working for us
they know the systems inside out but
they have to come from a different area
a long way away we're going to lose that
local knowledge and that's very very
important to have
is it democratic what the government's
trying to do
no
far from
it i've watched the question and answers
on parliament in the building
and now minister
stating that most of the councils before
this
i've been to lots and lots of meetings
around
and most of the council
are against it so
she's misleading parliament in those
situations and my thoughts which is not
a good thing for a democratic government
too
for the need to be democratic but in
this stage i don't think they are
the government is heading for revolt if
they try to force us through because i
can see
the big numbers of
our people here just don't want it to
happen and
revolts are nasty were to be put into
the council table
but
that's what
that could be going to happen if they
try to
undemocratically put this through and
originally we come to the
arrangement with them it was going to be
an all voluntary opt-in or opt-out
scenario
it's changing they're changing the
playing fields as we go
um
i'm not quite happy with um a 50-50 deal
with uh leading
with us in the um governance on it i
think we're quite entitled to have
[Applause]
local government new zealand's meant to
represent councils in new zealand
i don't think they're doing
their justice property because
they'd be naughty and putting out
statements that do not recognise the
majority of what councils think
and i think it's important for a local
government to
look at themselves and say
something's going wrong in our
administration here we're not giving
effects of what um the local councils
want so
i will be supporting this
recommendation 100
in fact
i probably personally think we're not
strong enough on this recommendation and
i think
you know it probably should be stronger
there but
um i'll 100 percent support it and
like counselor reading them there if i
had two votes i'd vote for it twice as
well thank you
thank you
for the speeches
to um in new material but i just want to
go back
to that dreaded earthquake time
the government said at the time
you need to run your own business
you need to make sure that you do your
own recovery plans you know your
community
far better locally than anyone else does
and that was a different colored
government at that time
and all the red government did
was put pressure on the blue government
to make sure that the label voice was
heard
interestingly
we get a three waters reform in which
they don't want to hear
from the local people
people who want to hear from the local
people where the local government people
it should have been government-driven it
is not
in fact they advised us not
to consult
with our people when our mandate in
everything we do is to consult with our
people
i'm not sure whether we have a communist
government or a normal government
then they can make their choice
on whether they decide whether we should
consult or not
that is just not good enough
i've been in the local government now
for just on 20 years
never have i had people talk to me on an
issue such as this they have on this
i get to walk down the street takes me
twice as long
and boy it used to take me a wee while
before so like you can imagine i don't
get much done during the day wandering
up and down the street with people
tapping me on the shoulder on the three
waters issues
and the government actually made really
good examples i give you uh fletcher's
i'm not sure how many times we've
bailed out flinches as a country for
billions and billions of dollars
the electricity reforms do they work
well
they're brilliant aren't they cheaper
electricity for everybody everybody gets
their dividends back in the country with
a load of rubbish
no more efficiencies in the
electricity business than there has ever
been before when it was run privately
the best people to run these
businesses are the local people
i have never yet seen
in all my time and we have done a
consultation on an annual plan every
year
in this
council i have never yet seen where we
have
submissions of people holding us to
account
for what it is that we do
governments have pushed down different
regulations to councils for many years
they have never funded them
and then when you can't fix a water pipe
because you are funding something else
that has been pushed down
you are irresponsible
well government it's about time you
started taking responsibility for
yourselves
[Applause]
we have systems in new zealand that work
for new zealand
[Applause]
that is just an example that could be
tweaked moved around or dancer something
to to fund those who need
it we've had exceptional staff and
consultants go through what we've what
it is that has been put in front of us
282 million dollars we're going to
invest in the next 30 years
if we are wrong by
twice that is 750 odd million dollars
and the government says that we need to
throw a billion dollars in there for a
while back why because that's a good
number it's just a billion it's nice a
round number we'll throw it in they can
afford to play it don't worry about it
they haven't got a bad deprivation
value well government we're not here as
your whipping boy anymore
we've had enough of being a whipping boy
it is time you took responsibility for
yourselves and you started looking and
consulting with people instead of the
dictation that is coming out of this
government we need to make sure that we
force that and that it happens
i agree with council williams that we
could we could be more forceful but i'm
not sure how could we be more forceful
than saying we're going to knock down
because i'm not sure what the other
option is um apart from taking our
suitcase in our lunch and going home um
you know
if we get locked out we're going to hop
down
it's as strong as you can get
um so look i absolutely support this in
front of us we've said two years talking
about this
um to be quite honest i don't believe we
have the information the information
that we've got is incorrect we've had
staff that
um
jared over there is losing his ear for
and i'm sure that he's had enough water
that he doesn't want to see anymore for
the rest of his life
but exceptional advice so um you know
thank you to all of our staff
but we need to we need to really send
those messages to the government and
make sure that they are listening
because up until now they have
but i thought my moment had passed
well it's it's
only when the writer replies being close
so you're welcome to speak to jewish
in addition to all of the previous
comments which i agree heartily with
i'll just add one or two
to the mix
the government analysis for this has
been rushed it's used broad high-level
top-down figures and they're incorrect
they say that we need to spend one
billion
of infrastructure
in the district
on our books we've got 282 million
that's a big discrepancy
so either they really really didn't
analyze things or else it's a case of
donors versus donaise
and they think that we have
maybe a spare 718
million dollars in our back pocket that
we can do allow to subsidize others
um dia really has no idea as it said
itself they haven't actually analyzed
our actual situation
and that's evident in their assumption
of us having a 360
percent debt to revenue reproduction
versus our actual largest projections at
its peak of 150
um if that were not the case we would
not have the double a standard rating
that we've got
our knowledge and assets and the
management thereof have been highlighted
as a benchmark yet the government seems
to have no knowledge of this when it
suits the agenda
if there is to be reform it mustn't be
rushed just to get it over the line in
time for the general election
they have rushed this process they
haven't looked at the details they've
used very broad high level
of assumptions
they've even come out and and been
honest with us and said well actually we
didn't look at your figures and whenever
you look at the dashboard that they
publish for wdc
with
its
glaring imperfections
incorrect numbers all across it
it's obvious so how can we trust that
this reform if it goes through in the in
the
form that it's being presented to us
here would actually deliver us anything
but another failed kiwi build
or something to that effect
there are some amazing
facts and figures in this report and i
commend everyone who had a part
in putting it together
and those are for them to read later and
i will leave it at that but i absolutely
support this council's position and
giving a very strong message to the
government that that we do not support
the reform as preferred to us today
thank you
[Applause]
thank you mr mayor i'll just be very
brief too i'd just like to commend my
colleagues and thank them for the effort
that's gone into this you know we've
debated this very very robustly for what
is it now a year or whatever the time
frame is we've gone into this in huge
detail and
it's evidenced today by the fact that in
40 minutes of contributions around the
table no one's come up with anything new
we are totally over this i mean i'm all
over it i mean we're actually over it as
well
on yesterday minister was being very
bullish and really confident actually
um by the end of the course she was less
so uh
uh an amazon report the can be merely
forum i really hope that she and the
government are definitely the same
and listening hard on this particular
topic
and i hope the choice has really
remained for our community
as we expected today and we will stand
up strongly for our community i'll make
that point really clear
d2
is what we're resolving here
as part of the resolutions informs the
government that the council will
strongly effectively oppose
government mandating the proposed
entity-based model for water services
delivery
following this meeting today
i'll be putting it really strongly to
the government on your heart and it's a
leisure that will come from all of us as
councillors united if this model is not
right for our community
i'm going to call the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
i do hear that carried unanimously well
done
[Applause]
all right um
this is the only piece of business
that's today
um so everything leave just to do to
clear any competition needs to be held
on
october at uh road 10 mccarthy's 17th
night next
tuesday so they hope to clear our
meeting close and thank everyone for the
irritants